COLLEAGUES WE DON'T FIGHT IT'S
OKAY TO COME ON.
>> Laura: A SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS HAVING
ITS OWN HEATED DEBATE OVER THE
FISA MEMO.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION IS
YOU HEARD THE CONGRESSMAN THERE,
HE HADN'T HEARD THE RUMBLE HE'S
AND HE CAN TALK ABOUT IT, I
DIDN'T QUITE FOLLOW THAT.
I'M GLAD THAT HE CAME ON.
YOUR VIEW ON THIS SITUATION
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING
REPUBLICANS ARE ANTI-FBI AND
POISONING THE WHOLE KIT AND
CABOODLE.
>> 35,000 EMPLOYEES IN THE FBI,
FANTASTIC PEOPLE KEEP US SAFE
FROM TERRORISM AND GANG
VIOLENCE, THEY WORK
EXCEPTIONALLY HARD, BUT IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT THERE ARE ALSO
MESSAGE OF THAT WORKED IN THE
EMAIL SCANDAL AND THEN WERE
HIRED ON TO DO THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL THAT CLEARLY HAD BIASES
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WERE
LET'S NOT A CHALLENGE, THIS IS A
CHALLENGE TO THE PEOPLE THEY ARE
FRUSTRATED WITH THAT ARE AT
HEADQUARTERS THAT ARE NOT
FOLLOWING BASIC FBI CODE AND
PROCEDURES.
>> Laura: DID IT BOTHER YOU TO
FIND OUT YESTERDAY THAT THE
THOUSANDS OF THOSE HILLARY
CONGRESS WASN'T TOLD ABOUT THAT
UNTIL A FULL MONTH LATER.
DO YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
GIVEN YOUR OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES?
>> I DO HAVE CONCERNS, I SIT ON
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE BOTH
OF THEM HAVING OVERSIGHT THERE
THAT THIS VERY.
ONCE IT'S EXPOSED AND JIM COMAY
BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THAT.
THAT'S INTERESTING TO SEE THEM
SIT ON ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
THAT ON ANTHONY WEINER'S
COMPUTER THAT HIS WIFE WAS
TRAFFIC THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
SECURED TRAFFIC BUT THEN IT IS
ALSO FORWARDING ON HER HUSBAND'S
UNSECURED COMPUTER AS WELL,
THAT'S A BIG CONCERN.
TWEETED THIS EARLIER TODAY.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
>> THAT'S A STUNNING REACTION,
CLEARLY THE FBI IF THEY HAVE A
BAD ACTOR THERE, THAT IS A
BIASED PERSON, THAT PERSON NEEDS
TO BE CLEARED AS WELL.
WE HAVE 35,000 GREAT FOLKS
NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE TO PREPARE
FOR THAT, THAT IS NOT TRUE.
DHS, WHEN HE LED IT, THEY
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN TRYING TO
PROTECT OUR ELECTIONS.
THEY ARE WORKING VERY HARD TO